this is a hugely significant week for
the monarch and her family and already
her relatives have been doing what they
can to
mark this week of remembrance but i
think for many of this this was the
confirmation that we were waiting for
and the palace have now confirmed that
the queen will be there on sunday for
that really important remembrance
at the cement half of course it comes
after a couple of weeks ago when we were
told that she would not be attending the
festival of remembrance which is an
event that the british legion holds on
because so basically said that she had
to rest for a couple of weeks time the
palace told us it was still her firm
intention to attend the remembrance
sunday event at the cenotaph
and of course that's not surprising the
queen of course a member of that wartime
generation she would have seen her
father very much rally the nation during
the second world war and has always seen
it as a really important moment for her
every year that she is there uh marking
that time on behalf of the nation
marking the sacrifices that have been
made um by so many but of course she has
already in the last
so a couple of big
engagements and also within this state
the palace have released this afternoon
they have confirmed that uh next tuesday
she will not be attending the general
synod service and opening session which
in essence is where clergy and bishops
gather together to debate and vote on
issues that are really important to the
church of england of course as supreme
governor of the church of england she
would never normally miss that event so
clearly doctors still cautious about
what they're allowing her to do and the
moniker self also at times continuing to
take it easy but yes at least we now
know that she will be there on sunday at
the cenotaph as the country pays their
respects